all right Jody
Jody oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Canton
Georgia
that's where I'm from so is that what
part of Georgia that's um north of
Atlanta It's about 40 minutes north it's
the country
tell me about how you grew up I grew up
um in a
a large family a very loving family it
appeared um however they were
very very strict Baptist I went to
church my whole life my mother
having when she was 16. my dad was very
abusive he was an alcoholic at the time
I did not know what drugs were so I
didn't know he was using a lot of drugs
later on I learned that he had been
using drugs but he would
probably every night from the time I was
bored to
um I would wake up him beating my mom to
death um
really really beating her his parents
lived in front of him
so um they would come down every night
and of course he never did anything
wrong and then one day my mom got the
courage to leave and she um she picked
me and my brother up my sister up from
school and said we're going on vacation
and we went to New York and uh we were
living there with her boyfriend and her
um that's the first time I ever smoked
weed I think was then
um I wasn't allowed to talk to anyone
from Georgia
um
and then you know I began to like New
York but um I started getting high all
the time just with weed and then PCP
and later on we moved back to Georgia
and I went to juvenile hall
um
and I think that was the moment that I
realized that um I hated my mother so uh
when she gave me to my grandmother after
that I am
went to my grandmother knowing I was
going to get to do anything I wanted to
do because they had money and they
spoiled me and I started doing ecstasy
um a lot of cocaine I used to smoke
crank it was called Crank at the time
which was crystal ice now
um of course I didn't tell anyone
because I cheered at school I was I did
very well at school
um but no one knew that I had this life
outside of school
um
and I think it was just an escape so uh
I guess I was just insecure my mom
wasn't around but um me and my brother
were always very close
he was selling cocaine at 15 16 years
old he's way too much apart um
so uh
he was very protective so he never knew
that what I was doing so it was always a
secret what I did but um math was
my best friend probably I would say it
nine ten days at a time knowing so new
unless they just wanted to be they knew
maybe they just wanted to not know I
don't know how many days nine ten days
at a time I would look at naps um but
back then you could do that with the
crank cranky good it wasn't like the
stuff now it would last a lot longer
um
but uh deliriously I'd be driving around
I mean my car and I I can't believe I'm
not dead honestly but
um you know I still hadn't never really
heard people overdosing at that time
because I didn't know what opioids were
or anything like that and then um
I actually got married and
you know thought I had found a new way
of life and quit doing drugs for a
little while and my son came and um his
dad joined the military and um
then we moved to Alaska so um that was a
really abusive relationship
um he put me in a mental hospital for
two weeks just for him just so he could
get an honorable discharge
and uh then he took my son for me and um
that was the moment I think I wanted to
die
because I had nothing to live for and
that's when I'm heroin became
my next thing
um
so I was sorting heroin and um
at that point I just I lived to get high
I lived to get high I tried methadone
clinic methadone clinics
um
and and they said that's just not not
all day that's nothing that's you lose
all sorts of morals all sorts of time
you just you're not the same person
um
I think um
my brother and me were very close we
both went to methadone methadone clinic
I remember living for the methadone
clinic getting up in the morning going
to the methadone clinic and that's all I
cared about and then I would buy more
methadone when I was there and then I
was taking Xanax on top of that
um
and I think I was just living to forget
what my childhood was and who I'd become
and I was stealing I was shoplifting I
had probably had
12 to 14 shoplifting cases at this time
um on probation
and
what's weird is um I did gymnastics for
18 years I was amazing and I was great
at it and um
I did good in school I did graduate high
school I went to pharmacy school
all that was just
somehow I maintained it and then like I
said it just went away when my son was
took from me but um
I think
my brother got locked up he was he was
like I said my best friend
um when we were little
I remember Joey and that's my brother
um
my dad was laying on the couch he was
passed out and Alec government has
um I got a thing of gasoline he's
pulling pouring gasoline around the
couch
and he's trying to set the couch on fire
to kill my dad and at that time I'm
thinking you know you're a kid so you're
not really you're not thinking but now
looking back it's like wow that was a
lot of anger there was a lot of um
for a four-year-old to one to kill the
father that's just a lot of how old he
was four at the time
and
and I think it was because maybe
my dad you know when we were younger and
he was beating up on my mom my brother
would always protect me so um I think he
just was more Fed Up than I was tired of
it he was tired
and you know later on they they I guess
amended the relationship and there they
became the shooting cocaine together but
um
I wasn't around for that they never told
me that stuff but um I was doing my own
thing
but uh
um
my brother had went to jail and
he was kicking indoors and houses
um to support his habit
I mean he would just go to any house and
kick the door in and go in and steal
whatever he could
and he got caught in a everyone said
don't don't don't bail him out don't
bail him out this is like his 20th time
in jail probably and my grandparents
always always bailed him out they always
got the money to do whatever they needed
to do
and um they wouldn't do it and I did it
and he died two days later I found him
dead in the woods
um
and I got they blame me for that
a lot of people did
um
they say he was he overdosed however it
was an investigation going on and he was
hot shot it was a hot shot which is
meaning someone had gave him a hot shot
which is something bad that as soon as
he didn't put in his veins it killed him
um we'll never know we've stopped the
investigation my dad just couldn't he
couldn't take it anymore
so that is the moment I went crazy
um
literally I went crazy I woke up and
and I realized he was actually I've been
at probably for four or five days we
searched for him in the woods for
probably two days first and
I I tripped over I ran upon his body and
um
he was there camping with his family and
uh
I don't know it was probably the worst
thing in the world happened to me
um because from that moment on I did not
care about anything I I thought before I
didn't care about anything I truly did
not care about anything
um
because the only person I had that I
trusted was gone
um the only one that ever loved me was
gone
um
so I mean life of life was just dark it
was really really dark and um
that's I began stripping I began
stripping that's when I began dancing
um
I don't really know if I did I didn't
need the money of course as for my habit
but I think more I did it because I just
wanted to get away from anyone and
everyone I ever knew because it reminded
me of him
but um
I had probably had warrants all the time
I always had warrants out I was always
on in some kind of trouble
um
so I began stripping and I made a lot of
money I made a lot of money and um
you know you do things that you just
don't think you would ever do
um
you become this person that you just
you lose all all morals you lose all um
I don't know I had no I had no respect
for myself I feel like I'm
that's something I thought I would never
do and my grandparents found out and um
my grandpa played Amazing Grace at my
door every day for two weeks I think
maybe he thought that would help
but really all they had to do was um was
probably talk to us no one ever talked
to us they just
they would just go buy stuff or you know
make up for what my dad wasn't doing
what my mom wasn't doing
um
my mom was completely out of the picture
by this time she had done a new family
and it's a millionaire that
she was in Iceland with and um
then she had just got pregnant with
twins actually
so um
I don't know so she she came to the
funeral for one day I think it was one
day and then
so just my anger towards her and then
and then bangers with my brother leaving
me probably was um the worst feeling and
uh
and then my son was gone so
I I was just I was I was completely lost
um
and then I probably got three years go
by and
you know I had met this one guy and um
he was actually friends with my brother
and uh
two years later I woke up he was dead
beside me he had been dead nine hours
and uh I was pregnant
and he he wasn't really a heavy drug
user
um
I actually talked him into going to the
methadone clinic because his back hurt
and I knew it was a way for me to get
there every day
it was selfish
um and I gave him one Xanax at night
because he was out of his and uh he
didn't wake up
he had been dead I remember
going to the kitchen kitchen and getting
a bowl of ice cream because I was
pregnant and um
laying down and I don't remember him
breathing and
I turned the light on and um
I guess the way he had been laying
everything had been the veins were all
alongside his face and I knew he said
but um
I called another one they told me to
pull him off the bed and work on him I
worked on him for
20 minutes 30 minutes it seemed like
forever not seemed very famous got there
but uh
they came in and um the worst I think
was telling his mother at the hospital
later about that day that uh her son was
dead she slapped me
uh I killed him she said
and I believe I blamed him I still I
still blame myself
um
he was a great I mean he was a good guy
he he went to other countries just to
build houses to help people
and
I'll never forgive myself for trying to
get him to that methadone clinic just so
I had a ride to go every day but um
so after he died
it was crazy he's done the same the same
thing was on his death certificate as my
brother
um evidence have been
opioids and methadone and Xanax that's
what that's their death certificate says
and
you know
I was never investigated never nothing
like that like for killing it nothing
like that but um I will always probably
blame myself for both of them
um
and you know people tell you all day
long it's not your fault it's not your
fault well actually yeah it is it is my
fault if I went and got him out of jail
he would not have died if I would not
have gave him
he would still be alive so it definitely
is my fault still
um
and I guess
all that
um what do you do you're sober there's
no way you can live sober like that I
did have to be sober for a minute
um I had I entered a drug court program
um I graduated with flying colors after
two years I've been sober did everything
right I played the role they wanted me
to play
the moment I was off I got high
um
I got high and I hadn't stop I've not
stopped since
um
I'm I recently moved to California
and um there's no heroin out here or
there is but it's called black tar and
there's it's not good heroin it sucks um
I think it sucks
uh it's pigeon they call it Pigeon Blood
so um
right now it's fetty fetty is the the
thing people everyone does out here so
um
it was that or B6 so right now that's
what I'm battling is the fetty but um
I moved out here with him my boyfriend
I've known 25 years he was my brother's
other best friend and
I'm just terrified that he's gonna be
dead because I have a really bad record
of
I feel like killing people but
um
I know I'm I know I'm a pretty girl and
I know I'm everyone tells me you know
you don't you know you can do have a
better life but really I mean
I've lost my kids I've lost my brother
my family um
they don't really answer the phone for
me
um his family's been out here twice if
it's him mine wouldn't even probably get
on a plane to come see me if I was dead
but
it's not because they don't love me it's
more for the fact that they don't
understand
um
and I can be sober I can be sober and I
can be happy to be sober but uh
I I think
I don't think I could be sober out here
not in California not here knowing I
have a warrant back in Georgia waiting
for me
and I have uh
I have a five-year-old now and I have um
11 year old and a 12 year old and of
course I have my 18 year old
and um not to mention I also have a baby
that um no one knows about because uh
I was raped when I'm my heroin dealer in
Atlanta
and
and the guy that died beside me he
thought it was his and he'll never know
because he died but um
I'd deliver the baby and um I put him up
for adoption to a really good family but
um
no one knows that I don't have ever said
that out loud
but
um
he is
um he's a mixed baby he's beautiful
but uh
he was addicted to methadone he was born
so he was in the Nick unit for a very
long time but thank God I had um I was
blessed with a very good family my
family never showed up for the
when I'm going into labor I didn't tell
anybody so um I was I gave labor I gave
birth alone besides the adopted people
and adopted parents and um they expected
this baby to come out white
they never knew
I never told him um
and they never knew they met never knew
anything different but they did not look
at any different they loved the baby I
mean but uh
you know sometimes I do Wonder um
what will I tell him my life if he ever
asked me what do I say
um
I don't know
and I think if
I don't know right now I mean I do have
a partner in life that loves me who
loves me but he's he's as well as a
heroin addict
um
it's it's that's your first love that is
your first love because that's the only
love that's going to stay there
but more than anything I would I would
if I could tell anyone anything I think
it would be not to
if I was never entered if I was never
introduced to maybe I would have done it
I don't know I don't know
but
I feel like I feel like
maybe I was dealt with shitty shitty
hand in life
um
but you would never know it meeting me
you would never know it
um
I mean I can smile and I can you know do
anything in the world I mean I know I'm
smart um
but I choose this life and I'm not
really sure why I choose this life
sometimes I feel like I choose it
because I want to make a difference in
people's just opinion on people I want
other people to see
just because you're a drug addict
doesn't mean
you can't
matter or just you can't be beautiful or
you can't be
you know you can't fit in a world that
that everyone talks about so great
that's not true
um
but maybe I'm full of myself I don't
know I don't know
um I've went to rehabs I've done
everything possible
um
my new thing is actually I called us a
boxing clinic today this morning
to Johnny to get on Suboxone
and try to do something better in my
life but uh
um
I don't I just I think that
I think the main problem was uh
my parents I think if looking back I
think that's where it all started was I
wasn't shown the right love I wasn't
shown that
you know no matter who I was or whatever
I was loved I was more shown
um I was more a mistake and I was more
the baby they had that they had to had
to keep and that ruined their life and
their childhood
and um
[Music]
my little sister she's in Georgia and um
she's she's very genuine very sweet and
she do drugs yes she has she does drugs
she does she smokes meth she does not do
heroin um
but I did give her a shot of heroin one
night and she she actually died on me um
and we brought her back to life and from
that moment I I couldn't believe myself
I'm
so maybe it is a battle of myself maybe
I hate myself I don't I don't know I
don't know what it is um
no I don't think anyone really has the
answer but uh
I don't know I think the world is just
crazy I think I think there's drug
addicts that maintain I didn't drug
addicts are everywhere
um
Bridge poor white bucket and everybody
there I mean and some just hide it well
some don't if you could tell me the
secret of life my my question would be
um
how do you stay happy server that would
be it I would want someone to teach me
how to be happy and be sober
that was that would be all in order
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently okay if I
oh if I could do anything differently I
would have
I would probably have
um
I want to stay with my mom I would not
have went to my grandparents house I
would not have hated her like I did I
would have stayed with her because
she was trying to teach me how to how to
work she was trying to teach me the
value of a dollar she was trying to
teach me you know hard work does the
right thing and it's just not instead of
manipulating
my grandparents and you get me whatever
I wanted and I knew I could get away
with it
that's what I would have probably done
that different I would sit there and I
wouldn't have gotten my brother out of
jail
um
I don't know I probably honestly if I
could have done anything differently I
would not have skipped school that day
and did meth for the first time
that's probably that's exactly what I
would have done differently
I mean I guess I I don't know and Jody
whatever you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
the most important lesson
I think it would be um
I think I should I should have believed
in myself more I really should have
believed in myself more and I shouldn't
have
everything I hated about my mother my
father I fell into it I fell into an
abusive relationship I fell into all
these things that I didn't want
that I saw her I saw that I hated it so
much but I became all those things so
what I should have done is there there
is an organization for a reason you go
to school for a reason you go to college
for a reason there's all these things
that are set in place for reasons and
I would have followed it more I would
have followed it more and I would have
um
I would have my own thoughts about
things and I would have had my own faith
about things
but I mean I do believe that there's
people in this world that bad things
just happen to
and they don't stop happening to them
and I'm not sure why that is
but
if you know someone like that
I would tell you to just just love them
through it and
just talking to them and letting them
know that you're there no matter what
it would make the biggest deal it'll
make the biggest the biggest difference
you'll ever see it's just
to instead of putting them down it's
really just to love them it's just to be
there for them
um the one person I would want to
forgive me more than any anything would
be my oldest son Isaiah
um
he didn't have a mother growing up at
all because his dad took him from me but
um
I think the dad never taken from me I
think I think that um I would not be
here today I would not be where I'm at
today I think that I think actually
that's it that that's it because holding
him was the first time I'd ever seen my
life mattered so I think if um
I think that if his dad would not have
took him for selfish reasons that I
would not um I would not be here where I
am today
taking a child away from a mother is
yeah that I I know that that's it that's
that's
I don't think I've ever said that is
definitely it right there can't give you
no reason to carry on
at all and especially when um
I was doing my I was doing my best at
the time I was doing the very best I
could I was sober
and I was trying to do this whole Leave
it to Beaver family Brady Bunch thing I
couldn't believe was happening to me I
thought he walks on water and he was a
good dad but as far as a partner
he was very very um
he made me feel stupid and he made me
feel like I was not good enough all the
time
um
but he went on and did his dream in the
military and
I made his dream come more true because
I don't know I was a crazy psycho That
Couldn't adapt to our surroundings in
Alaska so he got honorable discharged
and now making 250 000 a year and as a
pharmaceutical sales rep it has a
beautiful family and my son worships him
so
but I would never tell them I would
never tell my son that because I don't
want I don't know I'm about I'm better
than him I would never tell the things
he told
so
yeah that would be it would be Isaiah
Isaiah changed my life and uh Losing
Isaiah
definitely changed my life
so all right Jody thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I wish you lots of luck with
everything else from here on out yeah
maybe this time it'll it'll it'll work
out
I hope so all right thank you